all right this is my halloween gift to
you reviewing a movie that leaves you
feeling all warm and fuzzy inside
optimistic-like
yeah well first i want to thank the
sponsor of this video the ones that
facilitated this bonding experience
between us all there would be amc plus
celebrating their 25th year of amc's
horror movie marathon fear fest a myriad
of horror movie titles are available on
amc plus from now through october 31st
movies like halloween scream dawn of the
dead hellraiser the miss but those
movies are just a few titles tip of the
iceberg compared to what they have
available which i love that's what this
season is to me you know get a bunch of
friends together put on some horror
movies and just
bathe in halloween spirit so i do
appreciate the fact that fear fest
supplies that experience for
people like us us crazies out there just
love us some horror movies so click the
link below to start your one week trial
bask in the halloween spirit the way it
was meant to be with scary movies and
thank you once again to amc plus for
sponsoring this video and being such an
epic supporter of my channel in general
i do appreciate it and now
that ending
[Music]
so the mist is written for the screen
and directed by frank darabont which you
see from some of the walking dead cast
in here some walking dead season one
cast members in the myths based on the
stephen king book with the same name and
it's actually a very stephen king
feeling movie it's one of the more
stephen king esque movies out there that
i've seen you got this small town where
everyone knows everyone very castle rock
you got all the drama that comes with
that that's before the [ __ ] hits the fan
so the miss stars thomas janey lives in
a small town like i just described he
goes to the store with his son one day
then this mysterious mist starts coming
over the hills and the mist engulfs this
town this guy comes running from the
mist with a bloody nose like oh there's
something in the mist says some monster
snatch someone right in front of him so
everyone just kind of confines
themselves to this grocery store and now
here we are they're trying to wait out
this myth that never really goes away
and it has some great tense compelling
horror that i tend to like in movies
like this you know not only do you have
the monsters in the mist but you also
have a bunch of people in this really
scary situation so alright so people
start becoming dangerous too so what's
more dangerous the monsters are the
people that's really what i dug about
this movie alright first of all thomas
jane
is leading the charge he's the star of
this movie or i should say the movie's
the star of thomas jane is the thing i
nothing about thomas jane in this movie
makes the movie there's some moments
he's fine i mean he's a scared dad with
his scared kid in this scary situation
we've seen many characters like that in
movies like you know tom cruise played
that same role in war of the world
thomas jane in this movie
everyone around thomas jane is what
makes thomas jane work i mean sometimes
his acting is fine sometimes you're like
you're either overcooking it or
undercooking it i don't know which but
long story short he's fine but it's the
tension of the movie that sells thomas
jane it's the support characters helping
thomas jane out that do help him out
like andre brauer in this movie amazing
super memorable character until he's
gone just pretty quickly actually but
andre brauer plays exactly the role you
would think he would play in the stephen
king movie that neighbor you know he's
very stern very curt going to argue with
you about everything his character is
the kind of neighbor you don't want
living next door to you he's gonna argue
with you about everything you'd be like
fine bob i'll cut my [ __ ] lawn
okay marcia gay harden's actually the
scene stealer she's the one there's
always one in situations like this it's
always that person's like it's a sign
from the lord the end times it cracked
me up to see where she was like the
price must be paid the price for blood
lori holden just slaps her she has blood
on her mouth and she's like
another down payment another penny in
the jar i was like this lady doesn't
shut up thomas jane even addresses in
this movie he's like oh yeah people are
smart and they're civil until you cut
the electricity take all the power away
and they can't call for help and you put
them in a small contained space and you
scare the [ __ ] out of them and then you
see what happens which again is what i
love so much about the mist it's like
do we deal with the frying pan or the
fire what do we do do we stay here but
all right you have the scary people
situation but what about the monsters
out there you don't actually see a lot
of the monsters which i really dug about
the movie there's something scarier
about knowing that there are monsters in
the mist than seeing a bunch of monsters
on screen you do get a couple scenes
like one for instance a bunch of monster
bugs start coming through the windows
but that's my least favorite scene it's
like it's not as tense for me as dealing
with the dangerous religious zealots or
dealing with the unknown of whatever
might be out there well now we're seeing
it now we can smack it with broomsticks
and whatnot but again it's it's not
clean it's exactly what would happen if
you have a bunch of scared people and
fire i probably prefer not seeing the
monsters one for the tension but two
because it's 2007 cgi so you know that
was still when they were like we can do
anything it's like he can't do anything
let's dial it back a bit it's like as
the movie progresses the cgi got better
there's one shot in particular at the
end where i was like that looks really
good actually but the early monster cgi
when you just get a tentacle and it's
going after sherminator i was like that
definitely is standout cgi tentacle so
the movie actually played it smart and
showing the monsters sparingly or
showing a big silhouette in the mist but
you don't really get a good look at them
or maybe it's really dark lighting where
you've seen some of the cgi spiders dark
lighting helps cgi out also that scene
with the spiders that is the thing of
nightmares it's like the creatures in
here just
everything that's horrible and then it
gets worse big spiders that's terrible
what about big spiders that shoot
webbing at you that's worse what about
big spiders that shoot webbing at you
and the webbing burns through you like
acid
that's as bad as i can conjure in my
head we've hit peak [ __ ] no let's do it
but the horror elements in this movie i
felt were done well done sparingly
enough and done in context there's a lot
in the movie the miss that really worked
for me and the ending i'm not gonna tell
you what the ending is i'm not gonna
that that's something if you want to
experience it
you gotta experience it yourself i will
say the ending of this movie put me in a
foul mood for two weeks no [ __ ] i was a
grumpy [ __ ] for two weeks after
i saw this people be like good day
jeremy yeah just how [ __ ] good can it
be
huh the ending of this movie it sticks
with you not in that requiem for a dream
kind of way you know where he's like oh
man that's haunting
but earned the ending of this movie is a
trollish ending and a lot of people
[ __ ] hate it and they hate the movie
because of it and ending is one of those
things that can ruin an entire
movie-going experience i totally get it
i said
i really dig the ending of this movie i
don't know maybe it permanently tainted
my soul right i don't have any choice
but to like it i don't know i got
nothing for you i watched it again last
night it's like right when that song
hosts of the seraphim i believe it's
called right when that kicks on i i get
cold sweats and i don't feel okay and
that's not just in the movie anywhere
that song comes on
anywhere
i'm immediately not okay sometimes i'll
watch the ending on youtube you know
like like when things are going too well
i just a part of my brain's like no no
you get off of cloud nine you watch this
video i'll watch the ending like oh yes
right sorry for being optimistic there
brain
i'll remember my place i'm talking it up
i'm talking it up to brace you for
impact if you haven't seen it cause
you're gonna watch it now it wasn't so
bad you're welcome by the way the rest
of us went into this movie cold knew
nothing about the ending knew nothing
was coming we found no joy that
christmas the sun felt cold on our faces
our food turned to ash in our mouth but
ending aside or included the rest of the
movie
i thought really worked there's some
great horror elements in the mist the
things i like about stephen king
definitely in the movie the mist i'll
say the mist is definitely worth
watching and worth buying on blu-ray all
right so the movie the miss i know that
was a tv show we never saw the tv show
just
before you ask in the comment section
just letting you know but the mist have
you seen it what did you think about it
what'd you think about the ending what
did it do to your soul did you feel
leland gaunt walking out of needful
things with a briefcase where your soul
is like yeah got it now shouldn't have
watched the ending dumb [ __ ] whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you